[Music]
rainy day at the White House and some
breaking news late on a Friday a
district court judge US District DC has
a ruling on daca saying that the
administration has to restart this
program the deferred program that had
been kind of set aside the
administration wanting to stop that the
judge saying the court simply holds that
if the DHS Department of Homeland
Security wishes to rescind the program
or to take any other action for that
matter it must give a rational
explanation for its decision conclusion
certian that a prior policy is illegal
accompanied by a hodgepodge of illogical
or post-hoc policy assertions simply
will not do the court therefore
reaffirms its conclusion that daka's
rescission was unlawful and must be set
aside
breaking news calling a little bit of an
audible here with the panel let's bring
the man byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Molly Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalist and Charles Lane opinion
writer for The Washington Post okay
Byron impact possibilities well this is
one in a bunch of decisions we've seen
against daca and the president this
particular judge has been saying the
same thing for months now you've got to
give a better explanation for rescinding
daca a number of Republicans have been
saying no we don't the daca was was
enacted by President Obama on his
executive authority it could be
rescinded by President Trump on his
executive authority one more effect of
this though is there has been a lot of
talk about some sort of deal on Capitol
Hill for daca legalization in favor of
the wall or some of the other policies
the president wants Democrats don't need
to deal the courts are stopping or going
to keep daca alive and possibly restore
it they're doing their work for them
yeah I mean Molly it seems like it's
it's common sense that this thing was
not set up legislatively and would need
to if it had to go forward so reading
between the lines here the federal judge
is looking for a better explanation well
the Constitution clearly gives the
authority for this type of program to
Congress Congress is the one that should
be doing this
very similar type of program that
President Obama had was ruled
unconstitutional when state attorney
generals had challenged it it would be
exactly the same situation with this one
so it seems kind of unbelievable that
you would be told that this is something
that can't be done President Obama
didn't have the authority to do this but
somehow that was okay but when President
Trump tries to correct that issue by
rescinding it then he can't do it right
so this this is delayed till August 23rd
to allow the administration to appeal it
likely will and so then we go on to the
next question it's kind of interesting
because Justice Kennedy's resignation
took effect just a couple of days ago
July 31st so now we don't have nine
people on the Supreme Court and we won't
for quite some time so it will be a tie
four to four at the Supreme Court
probably if it comes up there which
means that this judge's ruling would
stay in place in other words the Supreme
Court is a little bit out of the action
or out of the game if that was where
President Trump was hoping to get his
his way in the meantime President Trump
at this rally are talking about
immigration specifically about border
security and I understand it you know
I'm a little torn myself I would
personally prefer before but whether
it's before or after
we're either getting it or we're closing
down government we need border security
the border security there Molly's
talking about a government shutdown
either before the midterms or after the
bottom line is that's a massive deal
including daca and border security
doesn't look like it's moving before the
midterms certainly doesn't look like
it's happening before but it's also very
difficult to do a shutdown after but I
do think President Trump is trying to
signal the importance of this issue and
remind elected representatives how
important it is for a huge part of their
base I want to turn to China tariffs
take a listen to this right now China's
not too happy with me China is in
trouble right now your economy is lousy
investors are walking out the currency's
falling china better take present
Trump's efforts
to solve the unfair illegal trade
their tariff problem their lack of
reciprocity their technology stealing
their their IP it better take president
Trump seriously we hope that the trade
policymakers in the United States will
be cool headed and listen to the voice
of US consumers and pay high attention
to the voice of the American business
community all right so this comes in the
backdrop of a July jobs report 107
57,000 jobs added in July unemployment
rate edging down 3.9 down from four you
have the changes since Trump took office
again we put these up every once in a
while but it's pretty interesting the
real GDP growth obviously the biggest
mover there but also a couple of other
changes and then the trade imbalance
with key US partners China EU Mexico and
Canada and it's pretty clear that
deficit with China is thirty three point
five billion dollars the question is the
patience factor that we talked about
here on the panel many times this is
more threatening from the president if
you if you make a graph of the tariffs
that the president has threatened versus
the ones that he has enacted there's
just an enormous difference between the
two now on the other hand as far as
political approval going after China on
trade was a promise the president made
over and over in the campaign it was one
of his biggest campaign promises we have
a lot of documentation from the US Trade
Representative about all of China's
trade offences force technology
transfers intellectual property theft
all of that stuff going after China it's
actually a good idea and it makes a lot
more sense and going after the EU or
Mexico or Canada so I think you're going
to keep hearing more and more with us
Mexico and Canada I'm hearing that
they're close on NAFTA and that they
could be a couple weeks away from
wrapping up that deal if that's true and
they actually get that done that will
relieve a lot of the pressure for some
of these farmers and others and it's why
it's important to remember what happened
with the EU last week as well China was
trying to cut a deal with the EU they've
been unable to we're able to do this
that is key if you believe the Trump
strategy is ultimately low tariffs and
ultimately dealing with all of China's
unfair trade practices they're doing
these high tariffs as a way to get to
low tariffs so the question really is
are you okay with China system of
stealing intellectual property of their
state control of so many businesses of
their unfair barriers or do you want to
change the situation if you want to
change the situation Trump is trying
this sort of risky tariff approach but
you're not hearing a lot of suggestions
from people who don't like it in the
meantime the RealClearPolitics average
of the president's job approval on the
economy is approve 15.3% to disapprove
42.4%
7.9 spread there that's an average of
recent polls I mean people are feeling
pretty good about what he's doing on the
economy and that's why I don't think
China will make any kind of concession
before our midterm election because as
that Chinese official sort of indicated
I hope the president will listen to the
voice of his consumers and his business
community translation we are trying to
encourage political backlash against
this president's trade policy and we're
gonna see if that works and if the
president and his party take reverses in
the fall election I think that's going
to make the Chinese feel vindicated that
he was less popular than he seemed and
vice versa but a recent poll did show
that business owners 71 percent of them
approve of tariffs on China so even
among the business community it's not
just that people are opposed to them
some people really support the idea of
going after and the question is how that
translates politically and we don't yet
know well the more you focus on China
the better it is politically for the
president I think there's no doubt it
played a part in his in his getting
elected and it could be used by
Republicans in 2018